opening statements begin today in Harvey
Weinstein's New York trial more than two
years after he was first accused in a
case that fueled the me2 movement more
than 80 women have since made
allegations against him
Weinstein faces charges involving two
women including rape and sexual assault
prosecutors plan to call for more
accusers from uncharged cases Weinstein
denies all allegations of non-consensual
sex CBS News legal analyst working
Kleman is here to help us understand all
this so Rickey put us into the minds of
these prosecutors who say they're going
to call four accusers from non charged
cases why would they do that same reason
that they did it in Bill Cosby trial two
is when you have a case that has two
accusers which they do here as the
charge misconduct and the crimes that
they're cases may not be strong enough
when there's no forensic evidence no
physical evidence late reporting these
cases are old going back 2006 2013 so
you get four others so there certainly
is value in numbers now when you have
that the prosecution says this is a
pattern of predatory activity and what
we have to do is see that he always
intentionally wanted to harm and attack
there is there a risk to that strategy
right there always is a risk to that
strategy what is that as well the risk
of course is that the prosecution can
say wait a minute
it's really beyond a reasonable doubt is
the burden of proof on the prosecution
and it's about those two women
and the prosecution knows how weak their
case is says the defense and that's why
they had to call for others so we have
talked to the defense - Harvey's defense
team and they seem very confident in
their case and how this is going to turn
out and now they're talking about they
have loving emails from some of the
accusers dozens upon dozens yes
loving emails I think is very
interesting is a term that they use how
effective could that be does that matter
I think it matters a great deal when you
have emails with one of the witnesses
saying that they want to introduce
Harvey to her mother another one who
says I have a new phone number please -
after an alleged assault after an
alleged assault and really loving and
fond emails that go on sometimes for
years what that is saying to the jury is
that these women were not sexually
assaulted or they were not raped however
how does the prosecution deal with that
so the prosecution calls an expert
witness the same expert witness that
testified in the Bill Cosby trial very
effectively a psychiatrist who is going
to say in rape trauma syndrome women
will often continue a relations and
every seven men and five women will be
interesting to see how they take this
case thanks Ricky
you